-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody!
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-What a crowd.
-That's fantastic.
-It feels great.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Well, guys,
this is very exciting.
Today, New York lowered
the COVID vaccine eligibility
to 50 years old.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So good news --
now every New York City hot dog
can get the vaccine.
-Aww.
-Yep, New Yorkers will do
anything to get vaccinated.
This morning, I saw Times Square
Elmo getting gray streaks.
[ Laughter ]
He was wearing a mask.
-Yeah, that's true.
-Yeah. Technically.
Dropping the age requirement
to 50 is super-exciting
until you go for your shot
and no one checks your ID.
It's like --
"Don't you want to see proof?"
It's like, "No.
You're -- You're fine."
My mom would do that
all the time.
Like, "I got my ID checked
today at the store."
I go, "They didn't think
you were 21 years old?"
[ Laughter ]
She really did do that.
Oh, gosh.
Honestly, this really means
that everyone's eligible
'cause, after the last year,
even kids look 50.
[Inhales sharply]
[Gravelly voice]
"What do I have to do
to get a Go-Gurt around here?"
Meanwhile, today in Russia,
Vladimir Putin
got his COVID vaccine,
but the Kremlin wouldn't say
which vaccine Putin got.
-Ooh.
-Yep, it will either be
Sputnik V, COVID-Vac,
or Smirnoff & Smirnoff.
The nurse asked which arm,
and Putin said, "Left pec,"
and then galloped away
shirtless on a horse.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, by getting the vaccine,
Putin made history
as the first Russian
to get injected with something
and live to talk about it.
[ Audience groans ]
I mean, normally,
when a Russian
gets injected,
they're either being poisoned
or preparing for the Olympics.
Let's be honest.
-[ Audience groans ]
-Woman: Nice!
-[ Laughs ]
I got a "nice" on that.
-Wow. "Nice!"
-Somebody said, "Nice!"
That's the thing about
these tinier, smaller crowds.
-They're intimate.
-Yeah, they're actual --
Verbal feedback.
-Yeah.
-"Nice!" All right.
I'll take "nice."
Speaking of the pandemic,
I saw that DoorDash will now
deliver COVID test kits
to your house.
Yeah, the DoorDash guy
will hook you up with fast food,
COVID tests, and, after
a long enough pause, weed.
[ Laughter ]
"Here's your delivery.
Here's your test.
[ Clears throat ]
All right. All right.
Let me see what I got."
I got to be honest.
It's a little strange
getting medical supplies
from the same guy
who bought you lunch
from Fuddruckers.
Get this.
I saw that the theme park
Disney California Adventure
just reopened.
That's right. You can pay $75
to walk around the park
and buy stuff,
but none of the rides
are running.
The CEO of Disneyland was
on the news to talk about it.
Check it out.
-We're certainly
going to be operating
under some significant
capacity constraints,
but there's still plenty
of things you can do at the park
like...
Ohh. That sounds --
That sounds fun.
"Hey. Hey.
We're on the tea cups.
We're on the tea cups!"
Some news --
Some news out of Washington
this week.
President Biden's team
is working on a $3-trillion
proposal for jobs, education,
and infrastructure.
Yeah. $3 trillion.
Does Joe Biden have a bunch
of bitcoin we don't know about?
Yep, the plan
will cost $3 trillion,
and it will be paid for
in quarters
Biden finds behind your ear.
"Hey, whippersnapper."
[ Laughter ]
Actually, to pay for his plan,
Biden may raise taxes
on corporations.
And you can tell
big corporations aren't happy.
This morning, when Biden asked
his iPhone for the weather,
Siri was like...
-Siri:
Try opening a window, bitch.
-Ohh! Indeed!
[ Applause ]
That is rude!
-This was interesting.
According to the White House,
Biden and former President Obama
talk on the phone all the time.
Yeah, it's strange
when those guys talk.
Half the time,
the other is thinking,
"Will this guy
wrap it up already?"
Biden and Obama actually
have a great relationship,
I mean, compared
to the last president,
who tried to have
his VP murdered!
[ Laughter ]
Some business news. I saw that
Popeyes just announced plans
to open its first restaurant
in the UK.
Oh, man, the monarchy is already
on the brink of collapse.
I don't think they can handle
a chicken-sandwich war.
Yeah, at long last, people
of the UK will be able to taste
that exotic delicacy --
chicken on bread.
[ Laughter ]
[British accent]
"My word, what do you call this?
-[British accent]
"Insane!
-This isn't a scone at all!
-Someone call
the Earl of Surrey!"
-It's a buttermilk biscuit!"
-"Wait. This chicken is fried!"
-Listen to this.
There's a new study
that found that, on average,
people gained 2 pounds per month
during quarantine.
Keep in mind,
some of that weight
is just layers of sweatpants
that are now melded
to your body.
People are like, "Whoa. Hang on.
I got injected with the vaccine.
That's got to weigh something."
We all knew something was up
because over the last year
either our masks got smaller
or our faces got bigger.
Do you know
what I'm talking about?
And, finally, this is crazy.
A Utah man's
Ring doorbell camera
captured four cougars
outside his front door.
Take a look at this.
Look at that.
Yeah. When he looked back later,
he saw an empty pizza box
and a torn red shirt
that said "Papa John's."
[ Laughter ]
You know when I heard
about four cougars on a camera,
I thought it was
going to be the trailer
for the new "Sex and the City."